my magic have you seen a few expire  gotta get other work in go extra go to  work because they work you know  especially we have had seven years just  morning fevers morning this morning  just waking up early getting the blood  flowing getting the juices right getting  ready for a little nine o'clock workout  the biggest thing in the morning waking  up getting your shake being  nutritionally sound 50 straight let's go  all day why are you tired  why do you try there you go you're over  rhythm just a price yep to be great  growing up here so right now we're at  the bottom under here tryna get up there  that's when in medicine  more MORE